It's been a weird time in the months leading
up to the release of Avengers 4.
When fans haven't been sobbing over the events
of Avengers: Infinity War, they've been crafting
intricate theories about how the surviving
crew might find a way to reverse Thanos' universe-decimating
snap and bring our fallen Marvel favorites
back to life.
Though it's a lovely thought that the turned-to-dust
gang will return, it may not actually come
to fruition.
According to Scarlet Witch actress Elizabeth
Olsen, things aren't going to get better in
Avengers 4.
Speaking at ACE Comic-Con in Chicago, Olsen
offered a blunt warning about the future of
Earth's Mightiest Heroes:
"It's only going to get worse."
Loki actor Tom Hiddleston joined Olsen on
stage for the convention panel, during which
he noted that both his character and Olsen's
Scarlet Witch had to make the ultimate sacrifice
in Infinity War, trading a life for the greater
good.
Speaking to Olsen, he said:
"The thing you have to do at the end of Infinity
War is a kind of sacrifice, and arguably Loki
makes a similar one."
As fans will recall, Loki died in the very
first scene of the film after trying to trick
Thanos.
"No resurrections this time."
Scarlet Witch's sacrifice came at the end,
when she had to kill Vision in order to extract
the Mind Stone from his forehead and destroy
it.
To make matters even more devastating, Scarlet
Witch didn't even survive Infinity War.
After killing her true love and then seeing
him die a second time, she floated away into
space dust, completely erased from reality.
The upside to Olsen's grim comments here is
that both she and Hiddleston will appear in
Avengers 4 in some capacity, despite biting
the dust in Infinity War.
Insiders previously spotted Olsen in Atlanta,
Georgia, filming reshoots for Avengers 4.
The actress herself also shared a since-deleted
post to her Instagram story that revealed
a bruise she got while shooting the film.
Olsen wrote in the caption of the photo that
the bruise came about while Scarlet Witch,
quote, "took flight," which suggests that
her character will be alive and well enough
to take to the skies for some epic action
sequences in the fourth Avengers flick.
As for Hiddleston, he isn't 100-percent confirmed
for Avengers 4, but set photos have shown
him filming what looks to be a flashback or
time travel sequence for the film.
"Surprise."
It's hard to imagine that, after all the pain
the Avengers and co.
suffered in Infinity War, things are going
to get even bleaker.
But might the intense doom and gloom only
last a short while before the heroes taste
sweet success?
Fan theories have it that Avengers 4 will
feature time travel, with the surviving heroes
banding together, taking a journey through
the Quantum Realm, and visiting the past to
defeat Thanos before he can collect the Infinity
Stones.
Leaked promotional art for Avengers 4 shows
Thor, Captain America, and Rocket Raccoon
wearing silver-white, red, and black suits
— ones that look similar to the costume
Hank Pym wore when he was searching for Janet
Van Dyne in the Quantum Realm.
Many have taken this as proof that Earth's
Mightiest Heroes will visit the past in Avengers
4, and will utilize the Quantum Realm to get
there.
Additional pieces of evidence that support
the time travel theory are the photos of Captain
America, Ant-Man, Hulk, and Iron Man on the
Avengers 4 set, filming a scene that looks
a lot like the Battle of New York from 2012's
The Avengers.
We've also seen leaked concept art that depicts
Captain America in what looks like his suit
from Captain America: Civil War and Black
Widow rocking red hair — the same shade
she wore in The Avengers and its sequels – rather
than the blonde bob she sported in Infinity
War.
All this considered, it seems highly likely
that Avengers 4 will start off super dark
before it turns back the clock and takes a
trip to Big Apple for Thanos-versus-Avengers
Showdown: Round Two.
With a little luck and a whole lot of butt-kicking,
maybe the heroes truly will be able to defeat
Thanos and revive their fellow vigilantes
so that everyone can live happily ever after.
Avengers 4 is set for release on May 3rd,
2019.